when the Emperor Arcadius was at the
point of death in Byzantium having a
male child Theodosius who was still
unweaned he felt grave fears not only
for him but for the government as well
not knowing how he should provide wisely
for both for he perceived that if he
provided a partner in government for
Theodosius he would in fact be
destroying his own son by bringing
forward against him a foe clothed in the
Regal power while if he set him alone
over the empire many would try to mount
the throne taking advantage as they
might be expected to do of the
helplessness of the child these man
would rise against the government and
after destroying Theodosius would make
themselves tyrants without difficulty
since the boy had no kinsmen in
Byzantium to be his guardian for
Arcadius had no hope that the boy's
uncle han aureus would secure him in as
much as the situation in italy was
already troublesome and he was equally
disturbed by the attitude of the Medes
varying lest these barbarians should
trample down the youthful Emperor and do
the Romans irreparable harm
when Arcadius was confronted with this
difficult situation though he had not
shown himself sagacious in other matters
he devised a plan which was destined to
preserve without trouble both his child
and his throne
[Music]
either as a result of conversation
certain of the learn it man searches are
usually found in numbers among the
advisors of a sovereign or from some
divine inspiration which came to him for
in drawing up the writings of his will
he designated the child as his successor
to the throne but appointed as guardian
over him is the Gerdes the persian king
enjoining upon him earnestly in his will
to preserve the Empire for Theodosius by
all his power and foresight so Arcadius
died having thus arranged his private
affairs as well as those of the Empire
but is de gerdes the persian king when
he saw this writing which was duly
delivered to him being even before a
sovereign whose nobility of character
had won for him the greatest renown did
then display a virtue at once amazing
and remarkable for loyally observing the
behests of Arcadius he adopted and
continued without interruption
a policy of profound peace with the
Romans and thus preserved the Empire for
Theodosius
indeed he straightaway dispatched a
letter to the Roman Senate not declining
the office of guardian of the Emperor
Theodosius and threatening war against
any who should attempt to enter into a
conspiracy against him
when Theodosius had grown to manhood and
was in the prime of his life and st
Gerdes had been taken from the world by
disease Veronese the Persian king
invaded the Roman domains with a mighty
army however he did no damage but
returned to his home without
accomplishing anything this came about
in the following way
Anatoli Asst general of the east had as
it happened been sent by the Emperor
Theodosius as ambassador to the Persians
alone and unaccompanied as he approached
the median army solitary as he was he
lept down from his horse and advanced on
foot towards Baron Aries and when
Varanasi saw him inquired from those who
were near who this man could be who was
coming forward and they replied that he
was the general of the Romans
thereupon the king was so dumbfounded by
this excessive degree of respect that he
himself willed his horse about and rode
away and the whole Persian host followed
him when he had reached his own
territory
he received the envoy with great
cordiality and granted the treaty of
peace on the terms which Anatolia sired
of him
one condition however he added that
neither party should construct any new
fortification in his own territory in
the neighbourhood of the boundary line
between the two countries
when this treaty had been executed
both sovereigns then continued to
administer the affairs of their
respective countries as seemed best to
them